la viruela cínica es una enfermedad
infrecuente causada por un
microorganismo muy pequeño llamado virus
de la viruela címica pertenece a un
grupo de Virus estrechamente
relacionados llamados ortopoxvirus otros
virus de este grupo que pueden infectar
a los humanos son el virus de la bariola
que causa la viruela el virus de la
viruela vacuna y el de la bacsinia
la viruela cívica es una zoonosis esto
significa que los animales pueden
transmitirle a las personas
se puede contraer el virus a través del
contacto directo con una persona que
tenga síntomas de viruela címica
especialmente durante la actividad
sexual si tiene relaciones sexuales con
alguien con viruela címica Es importante
saber que el uso de preservativo en sí
probablemente no evite que contraiga la
enfermedad Esto se debe a que el virus
también puede propagarse a través del
contacto con la erupción en las partes
no genitales del cuerpo los fluidos
corporales incluidas las gotículas
producidas al respirar y la superficie u
objetos que hayan utilizado las personas
infectadas como la vestimenta y la ropa
de cama además una mujer embarazada que
tenga viruela cínica puede transmitir el
virus al feto
pero los científicos no están seguros de
Si una persona con viruela cívica puede
contagiar el virus si no tiene síntomas
una vez que el virus entra en el cuerpo
se desplaza a través de los vasos
linfáticos hasta los ganglios linfáticos
cercanos donde comienza a multiplicarse
durante las siguientes una o dos semanas
el virus se propaga en el torrente
sanguíneo por todo el cuerpo durante
este tiempo llamado periodo de
incubación no tendrá síntomas usted
puede tener un mayor riesgo de contraer
la viruela címica Así ha tenido contacto
directo en las últimas dos semanas con
alguien que tiene o puede tener viruela
címica Especialmente con hombres que
tienen relaciones sexuales con otros
hombres en una zona geográfica en la que
la viruela címica se está propagando o
tiene un trabajo en el que puede estar
expuesto al ortopoxvirus como los
trabajadores de laboratorio y los
trabajadores sanitarios otras personas
en riesgo son aquellas que han tenido
contacto con animales como monos o
roedores que podrían estar infectados
están expuestas a objetos o superficies
contaminadas con el virus o no han sido
vacunadas contra la viruela si nació
después de 1972 Es probable que no haya
recibido la vacuna contra la viruela
como la mayoría de las infecciones
víricas la viruela cívica puede comenzar
con síntomas similares a los de la entre
los que se incluyen sensación de
agotamiento escalofríos fiebre dolor de
cabeza dolores musculares ganglios
linfáticos inflamados y congestión nasal
dolor de garganta o tos estos síntomas
suelen ir seguidos de una erupción plana
en determinadas zonas del cuerpo como
los genitales la región anal la cara la
boca las manos los pies y el pecho luego
la erupción puede convertirse en llagas
elevadas similares a granos llenas de
líquido o pus además la erupción suele
ser muy dolorosa esta erupción suele
durar aproximadamente una semana antes
de que se empiece a secar se forma una
costra y finalmente se caiga y aparezca
la piel nueva
si cree que puede tener síntomas de
viruela cívica o quieres saber más sobre
ella habla con su proveedor de atención
médica